[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
medical doctor from Nicaragua and I am
here once again to save as many lives as
possible in surgeon simulator 2013 let's
get started here okay we've got a
general interface of the similar
capacity shut up I need to operate on
medical patients of some sort so please
just shut up okay so what we have here
is a wer space controls that you've all
seen the other video let's get straight
to it oh I'm uh I'm operating on Bob
this should go well hello y'all know Bob
is a good friend of mine and he only he
would trust me with his life like this
because he knows the quality doctor that
I am unlike those other people from
Nicaragua
it's gone eh okay there we go all right
no need to panic just yet we're going
about it very calmly right Bob
right right Bob just we're calmly going
about this hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
it's okay it's all right I'm a doctor
I know what's best let's hold our anger
off for a little bit um the Medical
Board didn't like the way I treated the
patients before so this time I need to
be very careful in my excision of the
sternal cavity so let's take this
precision tool this expert precision saw
here and very delicate watch watch came
off hey I needed that
I need that what give me the damn thing
give it tonight I can see they vastly
improved the mechanics of the game here
well alright then I'm just gonna grab
one of these needles here and jab it
right into the patient's face
should help him out pretty good there we
go feeling better now
feeling good don't go buddy feeling good
alright grab it right in the eye yeah it
looks good you doing all right there
buddy
you're doing okay all right good good
okay you seem to be spurting blood out
of your face
oh I'm not supposed to be operating on
your face well what do you mean doctor I
think I supposed to be operating good
heart
shut up nurse I'm a doctor of course I
know what best okay all right let's um
besides stupid nurses aside let's
continue into the thoracic cavity our
patient seems to be losing a lot of
blood very quickly so let's try to heal
them off with these magical juices good
no I lost another one
okay next patient sorry Bob let's give a
mulligan on that one and uh see if we
can go about this a correct way sorry
about that Bob you feeling better now
you're feeling better Bob you're ruining
my reputation you know that right and
this stupid cloth Hey
I'm so glad they they improved the
mechanic of my arm no no Bob you ruined
me last time
you ruined me and Nicaragua you all
ruined me now okay okay okay now let's
try this sauce strategy again where we
grab the saw firmly there we go
now as I am a professional you need to
exercise the thoracic cavity one rib at
a time we don't have our professional
rib spreader here so we're just gonna
have to make do with best we can so
slice the ribs towards the outer
extremities so that they can wow these
ribs are strong these ribs are really
strong what the hell is going on here
these are supposed to get there we go
what the hell happened these ribs got
amazingly strong what the hell Jesus
okay maybe I got weaker ah that's okay
we're doing whoa boy these controls I
think they made the controls
okay all right that's okay I think they
made the Rick controls worse somehow
somehow I don't know how what they did
okay there we go
good golly what are these ribs made out
of Bob what have you been eating and
somebody's been eating their Wheaties
okay now let's see if we can strain the
last one here we're already losing blood
in an alarming wait okay it's just one
more and come on there we go all right
we're doing pretty good if I pretty good
I mean pretty badly just like back in
Nicaragua
when the doctors wouldn't pick me first
in Nicaraguan recess it wouldn't pick me
for the kickball team or the dodgeball
team but that's okay I don't have any
rib burger for repressed memories from
that let's grab the lung and rip it out
of there no need for that no need for
the other lung we're running out of time
though we need oh we need to hurry up
here we don't have much time it's okay
Shh Bob it's okay I gotcha I gotcha I
gotcha
I can't lose Bob again all right try
again take a second Bowl get on that
nothing too bad okay so I underestimated
the strength of the ribs which I should
have remembered back in a in a uncle
Jerry's medical journal that the ribs
are actually much stronger than they
look and my oh my watch popped off you
can have it you can have it it's okay I
just need to get this in proper fashion
so that I can grab it more apprecia
sleeve come on come on come on come by
you [ __ ] boomer they made the control
so much worse how could they possibly
made the control self freakin bad they
could have all day at Olli
they could have only gone up
we up to go get back you son of a [ __ ]
you think you could make fun of me are
you know what screw it I'm using the new
tool the old tools are obviously there
is a red herring and what I need to do
is I need that ah ha ha you son of a
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] okay I
don't have a good grip on it but that's
okay I don't need a good grip on it I
just need to be able to shore up these
these bones here with this drill and
then once I get into the ribs
then then no no no it's okay I'm gonna
be okay because I'm a doctor I'm a
praying medical professional trained I'm
brain in his brain drilling his brain
okay no I can't drill his brain brain
brain brain thoracic mafic it's crazy
sure we need 32 cc's of Hydra more two
pairs own to exercise my right top right
directly into the into the brain and in
the brain you beat me in all those
what's going on I seem to be in a
medical theater wait what happened to
this patient who who did this to you who
did this to you
man hey boy all right there it looks
pretty good all right huh let's just
step back for a second and cut them down
I need to understand what has happened
here I don't know but this drill seems
to have a mind of its own I need to let
that go for now I have to focus on the
patient all that matters is the
patient's well-being yeah okay
all right screw that all the other tools
are being like giant [ __ ] to me how
in the world is this back
[Applause]
there we go that's better now it's too
late now cuz the patient's about to die
but whatever you know you know who
really cares about surviving patients
it's all about quantity over quality
okay I'm really trying ladies and
gentlemen I'm really trying the
nicaraguan professes down in Nicaragua
they didn't train me for this they
didn't prepare me for what was going on
here okay now I actually am trying I'm
not trying to mess up I'm trying to
really do this but it's really freaking
hard how the watch popped off again
that's okay okay so let's just chip away
at the corners here there's one rib all
right that came off with some relative
goodness all right let's just chip away
the rest of him Patti its Mac yes this
stupid hammer it does not want to
cooperate with me I'm really trying
there we go minimal blood loss just that
was that that sternum that was not the
sternum it's okay hi maybe if I wasn't
holding the hammer and such a stupid
fashion good okay there we go yeah there
we go all right now we've got plenty of
time to get into this rib and see if we
can't help this patient survive what
have I got I don't even know what I got
there we go ripped a rib out just like
I'm supposed to just like daddy Tommy
daddy he never thought that I could be a
doctor he never thought I could be a
doctor doctor don't you think you should
focus on the bridge shut up nurse shut
up I just ripped out his long don't
think I won't do the same to you I'm
spitting all over the myself it's okay
spit does the body good it gets into the
patient who cares he's gonna die anyway
without my help he would have died
anyway so just think of it's nice for me
girl kappa there we go ah yeah feel
finally alright cut that long out of the
patient that bad boy was in there that
bad boy was in there pretty good ha ha
come on come on back here
come on back here do you see this Bob
Bob do you see this this is what's wrong
with you this is oh no it's not the
problem oh it's in your heart the thing
your heart your say shut up Bob I know
it's wrong with you I know it's wrong
with you
yeah I'm operating on you that's what's
wrong with you but okay all right
now we've properly calm the patient and
now we can move on to removing what
other faculties remain I don't know what
this is but it doesn't look too
important all right so we've got the
thoracic cavity properly exposed here
I've grabbed onto something that it does
not want to okay all right it wasn't
that important anyway so now that we
have exposed the heart we just need to
cut the remaining limbs very delicately
so let's use a precise surgical
instrument known as the scalpel hola
back in my Nicaraguan country of home
origin and training so we've got one
here I think I'm pretty sure we do yeah
we do so let's just get it in there and
start slicing very carefully at the
arteries need to slice the arteries in
order to be able to remove the heart
it's cut cut you bastards cut cut cut
okay wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I cut something else here something
else what is this
it's a giant bag of bile in here well
that can't be good for the patient Bob
come on now yeah come on Bob just give
it to me just give it up man it's not
worth it it's not worth it it's not
worth it is annoying come on Bob
cooperate with me Bob
Bob mr. Babbitt give it to me give it
away
okay obviously it's not out enough it
needs to be out more needs we are much
more so I need to take this Landy to get
it up manually electronically manually
with the aid of super technology that we
didn't have back in Nicaragua have we
got it
of our cottage this was an adventure
into madness that I had not foreseen so
I lost many patients today many patients
they seem to have made it harder for me
my hands aren't what they used to be I
suppose I must end my career here thank
you all so much for watching I'm sorry
Bob I couldn't save you anyway
I'd like to thank my nurse thank you
nurse I know at first
[Music]
I'd like to thank all of you for
watching and learning from this so
please take this as a lesson if you
trust me with your life you made a bad
decision so thank you all for watching
click the annotation more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
you think I'm calm
you think I've come well of course I've
come I don't even know until this cavity
the lungs
areolas the nipples the penis the vagina
that's all I know
that's all I'm ever gonna know you think
you
okay